digital signatures have become a part
and parcel
of the everyday correspondence in the
corporate sector the pandemic has
further accelerated the need for digital
wears to become mainstream in the
business world
while we have already learned regarding
the dsl algorithm which is exclusively
used for verification
and transmission of signatures the rsa
algorithm can be used for general data
encryption and decryption as well
functioning on a similar public key
cryptography architecture
it is seen as a more complex solution to
bolster security
let us take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we first get a recap on what asymmetric
encryption is
and how is it any different from
symmetric encryption
we learned what digital signatures are
and how they are used in today's world
we understand how rsa system works and
how it can be used to encrypt
and decrypt general data apart from the
digital signatures
finally we learn about the advantages
rsa provides
when it comes to managing signatures and
encrypting information in a professional
environment
let's take a look at what asymmetric
encryption is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys in play
here a private key and a public key
a public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit
and the private key is used to decrypt
the data post transit
this pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message
the public keys can then be shared via
messaging blog posts
key servers and there are no
restrictions for it as you can see in
this image
two keys are working in the system the
sender first encrypts the message using
the receiver's private key
after which we received the ciphertext
the ciphertext is then transmitted to
the receiver without any other key
on getting the ciphertext the receiver
uses his private key to decrypt the
ciphertext and get the plain text back
there has been no requirement of any key
exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetric key cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt messages
and the private key which is known to
everyone cannot decrypt messages
it doesn't need to be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can
exchange personal data using the same
set of keys for as often as possible
in the current scenario if we have two
people mary android who wants to send
messages to each other
mary must use roy's public key to
encrypt the information before passing
on the cipher text to roy
on receiving the cipher text roy can use
his private key to decrypt the data
and get the plain text back like we
highlighted earlier
both the keys belong to roy who is the
receiver in this particular interaction
we now have a revision on how asymmetric
encryption works
let us understand what digital
signatures are and how they work
the objective of digital signatures is
to authenticate
and verify documents and data this is
necessary to avoid tampering and digital
modifications
or any kind of forgery during the
transmission of official documents
with one exception the work on the
public key cryptography architecture
typically an asymmetric key system
encrypts using a public key
and decrypts with a private key for
digital signatures however
the reverse is true the system is
encrypted using the private key and it
is decrypted using public key
because the keys are linked together
decoding with the public key verifies
that the proper private key was used to
sign the document
thereby verifying the signature's
provenance in step 1
we have m which is the original plain
text message
it is passed on to a hash function
denoted by h ash
to create a hash digest h
next it bundles the message together
with the hash digest
and encrypts it using the sender's
private key it sends the encrypted
bundle to the receiver
who can decrypt it using the sender's
public key
once it decrypts the message it is
passed to the same hash function
to generate a similar digest it compares
the newly generated hash value
with the bundle hash value received
along with the message
if they match it verifies the data
integrity
in many instances they provide a layer
of validation and security to messages
sent through a non-secured channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver
reason to believe that the message was
sent by the claimed sender
digital signatures are equivalent to
traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects
but properly implemented digital
signatures are far more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type
digital signature schemes in the sense
used here are cryptographically based
and must be implemented properly to be
effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning the signer cannot successfully
claim they did not sign a message
while also claiming their private key
remains secret
further some down repudiation schemes
offer a timestamp for the digital
signature
so that even if the private key is
exposed the signature is valid
to implement the concept of digital
signature in real world practice
we have two primary algorithms to follow
the rsa algorithm
and the dsa algorithm the former is a
topic of learning today
so let's go ahead and see what the rsa
algorithm is supposed to do
the rsa algorithm is a public key
signature algorithm
developed by ron rivest adi shamir and
leonard edelman the paper was first
published in 1977
and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough
to withstand brute force and streamlined
enough to be fast post deployment
rsa can also encrypt and decrypt general
information
to securely exchange data along with
handling digital signature verification
let us understand how it achieved this
we take our plain text message
m we pass it through a hash function to
generate the digest h
which is then encrypted using the
sender's private key
this is appended to the original plain
text message and sent over to the
receiver
once the receiver receives the bundle we
can pass the plain text message to the
same hash function to generate a digest
and the ciphertext can be decrypted
using the public key of the sender
the remaining hashes are compared if the
values match
then the data integrity is verified and
the sender is authenticated
apart from digital signatures the main
case of rsa is
encryption and decryption of private
information before being transmitted
across communication challenge
this is where the data encryption comes
into play when using rsa for encryption
and decryption of general data
it reverses the key set usage unlike
signature verification
it receives the receiver's public key to
encrypt the data
and uses the receiver's private key in
decrypting the data
thus there is no need to exchange any
keys in this scenario
there are two broad components when it
comes to rsa cryptography one of them is
key generation
key generation employs a step of
generating the private and the public
keys
that are going to be used for encrypting
and decrypting the data
the second part is the encryption and
decryption functions
these are the ciphers and steps that
need to be run when scrambling the data
or recovering the data from the
ciphertext you will now understand each
of these steps in a next subtopic
keeping the previous two concepts in
mind let us go ahead and see how the
entire process works
starting from creating the keeper to
encrypting and decrypting the
information
you need to generate the public and
private keys before running the
functions to generate ciphertext and
plain text
they use certain variables and
parameters all of which are explained
we first used two large prime numbers
which can be denoted by p
and q we can compute the value of
n as n equal to p into q and compute the
value of z
as p minus 1 into q minus 1.
a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions
and a number d is also selected at
random following the formula
e d mod j equal to 1 and it can be
calculated with the formula given below
the public key is then packaged as a
bundle with
n and e and the private key is packaged
as a bundle
using n and d this sums up the key
generation process
for the encryption and decryption
function we use the formula
c and m the ciphertext can be calculated
as
c equal to m to the power e mod n and
the plaintext can be calculated from the
ciphertext
as c powerd mod n when it comes to a
data encryption example
let's take p and q as 7 and 13.
the value of n can be calculated as 91.
if we select the value of e to be 5 it
satisfy all the criteria that we needed
to
the value of d can be calculated using
the following function
which gives it as 29 the public key can
then be packaged as 91 comma 5
and the private key can then be packaged
as 91 comma 29.
the plain text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m
ciphertext can be calculated to the
formula c
equal to m to the power e mod n which
gives us 82.
if somebody receives this ciphertext
they can calculate the plaintext using
the formula c
to the power d mod n which gives us the
value of 10
as selected as our plain text we can now
look at the factors that make the rsa
algorithm stand out versus its
competitors
in the advantageous topics of this
lesson
rsa encryption depends on using the
receiver's public key
so that you don't have to share any
secret key to receive the messages from
others
this was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography structure
since the key pairs are related to each
other a receiver cannot intercept the
message
since they didn't have the correct
private keys to decrypt the information
if a public key can decrypt the
information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key
without admitting the private key is not
in fact private anymore
the encryption process is faster than
that of the dsa algorithm
even if the key generation is slower in
rsa many systems across the world tend
to reuse the same keys
so that they can spend less time in key
generation and more time on actual
cipher text management
data will be tamper proof in transit
since meddling with the data will alter
the usage of the keys
the private key won't be able to decrypt
the information hence alerting the
receiver
of any kind of manipulation in between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
transit the cases of which are rather
low
hope you learned something interesting
today if you have any questions
regarding this topic
feel free to ask us in the comments
below and we will be happy to answer
your question
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here